I have a 595 rule 5% anytime planning
95% anytime doing where most people are
their flip it's like 95 percent I'm
planning and you make a plan and you
take one small step and then you have to
sit back and plan again and you're
thinking and strategizing and and
worrying about will this work for naught
and what will people say it's like just
do it and then see the top ten series
started three years ago but I had my
channel for a long time before I started
the top ten series and so like what if I
give up what if I gave up before I
started making my tough that like top
ten series the most iconic series I
think on my channel right now came so
recently in the history but by continue
to make contents like the evolution like
don't worry about what you're making now
it'll evolve to something else
it's not a final product that what you
guys are creating because you record and
it sucks and then you want to post it
like post it feel the suck the suck is
the best I want it I want to hit the
suck amazing and then improve and get
better and better better better better I
love having a schedule my schedule keeps
me productive the thing is when you're
when you're planning you want to create
the schedule that will set you up for
success and then just follow the
schedule right so I have a 595 rule 5%
anytime planning 95% any time doing 5%
of time planning 95% of the time doing
the 595 rule where most people are there
flipped its like 95% any time planning
and you make a plan and you take one
small step and then you have to sit back
and plan again and you're thinking and
strategizing and and worrying about will
this work or not and what will people
say it's like just do it
and then see bless you this doesn't
count this is all planning this is all
ideas and strategizing this does not
count as doing coming here does not
count as doing doing will be like going
out and making a story like great you
came awesome invested in yourself but
this is just like we're just getting to
the water you have to do we're a lot of
people this is what the dude like you
read a book or you'll watch your video
watch go to some
and then you you said like professional
seminar goers you gotta take action
right like I want to I want to copy up
for being here awesome but also like
this is nothing don't praise yourself
for this tie your result tie yourself
respect to the effort that you put out
the action the doing so 595 I had a I
had Instagram live with the woman
yesterday who she wants to solve melt a
mental illness so she wants not to
endless to not be an issue anymore great
like that's never gonna happen in your
lifetime I love it I mean like I think
you should have a goal so big that
you're never gonna do it right I'm
trying to solve the world's biggest
problem so we're gonna happen I love it
that's the best right you wake up when
you empty a spoon from the ocean and
that's what you do every day right
you're never gonna be the ocean so you
have a goal so big and then she wants
she wants to do it through podcasting
great so as podcast is still the
strategy yes awesome don't think about
it again for the next quarter
the next quarter the next three months
just do everything need to do for
podcasting and she's humming and hawing
about like oh what's the perfect email
to send out and who is this still the
best strategy and I'm gonna change that
that intro 5,000 times before I launch
like go do it stop thinking about it and
do it thinking is important but thinking
too much hinders you actually making
progress
I love strategize and I love planning
and I learned this mistake early because
I lost a 40 million dollar deal when I
was 21 years old because of planning too
much we were I had about six offer
companies my first business when I was
19 and we're building it up and we had a
opportunity to sell our business and I
was planning I spent like the whole
summer come with the perfect plan of who
was gonna buy us in a perfect plan and I
missed the target like I picked the
wrong company I picked the right
industry but I picked the wrong company
and so when the right company came along
we were late to the table and we ended
up being the second choice and the last
a 40 million dollar deal because of it
that's right
21 years old older than fantastic so
then then I got I'm a perfectionist I
got to get on my own way I love planning
I love strategize and it's so great to
think of like what I can build right
like where this can go when the books
and you know you get so excited we're
dreamers but you got to do so five
percent of your time planning
ninety-five percent of time actually
executing I'm the same way I hate
launching something before it's ready
and so I have to launch it before it's
ready you either focus on the million
reasons why you're not gonna win with a
five how you will write there's a
million reasons why you will not win and
they're all legit and valid and we can
all come up with a million more on top
of what you're ready telling yourself
but there's five of how you will win and
that's all I focus on so for me I have
the same problem as you guys when I
redid my website I have a bunch of
pictures even now it's pictures there's
no text there's no SEO anything you
can't read it
it's all pictures and it was a single
landing page I threw away a website that
had hundreds of thousands of views
coming in I just deleted the whole thing
and threw up a one page landing page of
like this is coming and it came with my
circle potential idea and just put that
up and because I hate that so much it
forces me to keep working on it so I put
up the one pager and I hate looking at
my one pager so that forces me to keep
working on it so that I don't have to
look at anymore where if I'm just
planning when I'm gonna launch my
website then legaia plan yeah and
there's no urgency you can launch it
whenever you can launch your podcast
whenever there's no urgency but if first
one went up and you want to do one a
week now you have some real urgency if
they go out and do it so like you should
launch your podcast today too
that's great we're just watching
everything but it's like just go like
make it and then and then feel the burn
of how embarrassed you are by that first
one going up and how much pressure there
is as long like I use as a kick forward
not down I use a critique and the burn
not to say I suck but I'm this a bush to
get better so I look to wherever your
heroes are I look at Les Brown young Les
Brown is my is my like speaking hero and
I look at young Les Brown and it's easy
to say well I can never be like Les
Brown look at how good he is but it's
unfair to compare the start of your
journey to somebody else's middle or end
right if you look at what I'm doing well
you can't do that yet it's awesome you
have to start look at what I did at the
beginning you probably better than I was
already I look at as inspiration to kick
forward like look at what's possible
look at what can be done I may never get
to that level I mean never get to be Les
Brown level but I'm gonna work like he
inspires me to want to go off and be
better where a lot of people look at at
and they beat themselves down and say I
can never do that right so focus on the
five reasons why you can't win so like
both you guys need to post put it up
feel the burn like no channel artwork
crappy descriptions everywhere yeah get
used to it get used to posting because
the momentum of posting is way better
than being perfect you don't even know
what perfect is that's the problem
you think it's perfect and then you see
something else they say oh no that's
perfect I need to stop and go like tweak
it to make that happen and then it's
perfect you're in the ultimate momentum
losing zone right now if it's strategy
then like how do you refine your
strategy you have to execute you're not
gonna come up with a perfect strategy
just sitting here you got to test it and
do it right it's like the grass is green
on the other side you don't know you got
to go and try it is sushi the greatest
food of all time I don't know go try
sushi and then you'll know right that's
not strategy and I love strategy I'm all
about strategy but your strategy gets
better through execution
so my dogs are with me well Teemo hello
team ah he's just chillin up at my feet
huh so last time Christina was here she
was a super puppy she's six months old
now may was however a months ago when
that's when she was here she came in on
day three peed everywhere like this is
the best right we had at we had awesome
part of our breakout sessions the fire
alarm went off it's the best like it's
through the adversities that you'd grow
like if a fire erupted here and we all
had to like leave it be the best because
what we're gonna do like we're gonna go
out and we're gonna we're gonna finish a
session on the street corner I'm gonna
stand up on some box and we're gonna
finish this like this is happening and
it'll be the greatest experience of all
time like you guys will have a memory
much more than just sitting in a
classroom here so it's like if you're
feeling the burn you're feeling the fear
of perfection then you have to crush it
by releasing imperfect things because
the momentum is more important than
having a perfect product raise your
standard cool it's core value not one
drop of my self-worth depends on your
it's something Sammy this interview was
done as a part of my Toronto workshop if
you want more details on the next one to
sign up check out the link right there
next to me continue to believe and I'll
see you there